cette soirée avec un immense succès et
c'est grâce à toi on n'a qu'à laisser la
voiture là et prendre un taxi tu sais
quelle heure mes parents rentrent ta
maman m'a envoyé un texto pour me dire
qu'ils allaient partir
tu pourra leur dire de venir me dire
bonne nuit quand ils rentreront
je suis sûr que c'est rien tu n'as
absolument rien à craindre
on est marchand d'art on voyage un peu
partout pour vendre des oeuvres
inestimable
vous savez un jour j'aimerais vraiment
avoir tout ce que vous avez
je vous prie
trouve là effet la terre
tout va bien
ouais
on n'avait pas prévu de faire du mal
[Applaudissements]
mais la gamine je la trouve pas
n'oublie pas pourquoi on est là il faut
concentrer nos plans
[Applaudissements]
à
je crois qu'ils sont prêts
il devrait arriver d'ici quelques
minutes contente toi de faire comme on a
dit pareil de mon côté
pitié ne fait rien à ma famille
[Applaudissements]
je peux pas me faire confiance
vous savez un jour j'aimerais vraiment
avoir tout ce que vous avez